and um
so i mean this next part's gonna [ __ ]
kind of sound kind of bad
on my part would you snitch oh for sure
i did yeah i'm not going back to prison
right i'm not going back to prison okay
listen these [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] these [ __ ] you know what i
mean that's my attitude right
i'm not going back to prison for these
[ __ ] that i don't even know
right
you know what i mean so they want the
lab we want the lab i'm like all right
so this dude is the mastermind i told
him you know what i mean this dude's the
[ __ ] mastermind i threw buddy under
the bus
i'm sorry buddy if you ever watch this
i'm [ __ ] sorry
his name is buddy no his name's not
buddy oh okay
i'm [ __ ] sorry dude i apologize but i
wasn't going back to prison i apologize
yeah my bad um who was the who it wasn't
the secret service though
that grabbed you it was no this was the
miami financial crimes unit
so it hadn't i was like is this federal
that's the first thing i asked him i was
like is this federer's like no it's not
federal
i was like okay now i got some wiggle
room then i knew i had some wiggle room
you know what i mean because if it's
feral you're [ __ ] you're done
they're just gonna indict you and then
you can cooperate and then you're still
going to be you're getting your prison
prison yeah so if it was federal i was
like you know what let's go right now
right because it would have done me no
good to [ __ ] to do anything
but it was it was local so i knew i had
some wiggle room you know you can you
can
you can work with them so i gave them
the dude's [ __ ] address
and then the dude [ __ ] calls me while
they're there
all this is happening this this is just
a wrong [ __ ] day dude
yeah the wrong date the dude calls me
because we were waiting on the embosser
to come in and i was because
the lab was at his house because i was
like that's what i told him to do was
like dude i'm not
setting all this [ __ ] up i got my
[ __ ] probation officer comes over
here right she's going to come in here
and see would you ask me questions about
all this equipment when he's supposed to
have a [ __ ] laptop
um so we had all [ __ ] stood up at his
house
he calls me while they're there i'd put
on a [ __ ] speaker phone
he's like oh yeah yeah yeah he's talking
to me and he's like you know did it show
up i'm like yeah it's here he's like uh
come drop it off now i'm like i can't
really do that and they're like
they're both like [ __ ] i'm like all
right where do you want to meet at
so he's had me meet him at this [ __ ]
uh i don't remember what it was like a
publix or something like that
and he's like oh we gotta we gotta mic
you up we gotta mic you up i'm like what
the [ __ ] are we talking about like
listen i'm not wearing a wire man what
the [ __ ] you guys talking about you know
what i mean like
he's like no no it's not like the movies
you know what i mean they brought me
like a [ __ ] pager
and the pager was like a listening
device it was like a microphone and i
had to [ __ ] wear it in my pocket when
i went and dropped the [ __ ] the thing
off to him yeah
so i drive so i meet the dude at publix
i dropped the [ __ ] um i dropped this
is this whole story is wild
i dropped the [ __ ] i dropped the um
the thing off with him i wear the
[ __ ] listening device
once again dude i'm sorry i wear the
[ __ ] listening device you know what i
mean
i'm [ __ ] such a piece of [ __ ] for
this dude i i'm 100 but i'm not going
back to prison right you know what i
mean right [ __ ] that i'm not going back
to prison right
dude i'm sorry so um yeah i'd wear the
listening device on buddy and then
[ __ ]
immediate publix meet at publix i
dropped it off i met with him
uh i drove somewhere and then one of the
one of the two dudes that were there met
me there they followed
um him to his house and then called in
[ __ ] reinforcements and they [ __ ]
raided his house and found all the
equipment
everything they found all the equipment
so he was like um
he's like all right he's like you can go
the dude at the thing so you can go
i was like all right he lets you walk
let me walk but he's like we'll be in
contact with you
and he's like you know we have to we
have to report this to your probation
officer
we have to which by law we have to right
so i was like well
all right [ __ ] i'm on i'm running
you know what i mean because now i got i
got a little while to get to my back to
my [ __ ] apartment pack a bag and get
the [ __ ] out of dodge you know you're
gonna get a probation violation
one thousand percent i'm gonna
definitely go back
even the state says we won't okay we're
not going to charge them
i was federal illegal activity which is
clearly a [ __ ] violation of the rules
of my [ __ ] conduct my probation
yeah doesn't matter clearly they don't
want me [ __ ] printing credit cards
you know what i mean
or attempting or hand they can they can
they're going to they're going to
violate for any something like that
they're going to violate you
right yeah anything yeah so i take off i
go back to my
my my little apartment i had um and at
this time i
we hadn't even started making any money
yet at this time like i was still
[ __ ] working at the warehouse i still
really didn't have [ __ ]
i mean a little bit of money because i
was doing um we were making cards so i
was going out and doing a little bit of
store carding
and [ __ ] you know i mean just to have a
few dollars here and there because i was
i was doing bad dude i was doing [ __ ]
bad
i went up to the used car lot at the end
at the end of the street and got a
[ __ ] old
2003 cadillac [ __ ] uh uh
uh dhs or some [ __ ] like that i mean it
was [ __ ] it wasn't
you know my former glory if i was trying
to get back to my former glory you know
you ever see that [ __ ] movie kingpin
with um you might be a little bit too
young for that one it's got woody
harrelson
in it and he's got he's got he's got
that he's got the gto
and he's young and he's [ __ ] you see
him like years down the road and the
gto's all [ __ ] up and he's bald and
[ __ ] like that was me trying to make a
comeback
and here i am trying to make a come try
[ __ ] i got the cadillac you know what i
mean i'm starting to play cards again
i'm doing all right
you know but then i got we all got
[ __ ] up but at least i gave you the
heads up that they're gonna
notify your probation officer right so i
got i had a little bit of time so i i go
back to my condo
my apartment and i pack a bag and i call
um
i called my cousin in detroit and i was
like yo he's like
i need to come i need to come home i
need to come up there
and he bought me a plane ticket and i
drove my remember i drove my cadillac to
the airport and i just left it at the
airport and i hopped on a plane because
i had no intention of ever coming back
to florida right at this point
i mean i did maybe but not in the same
car in the same apartment in that you
know
so i left i left the [ __ ] car at the
airport and i flew to michigan um
and i hung out in michigan let me see i
got out of halfway house and uh i got a
halfway house on my 30th birthday
is when i got out of the halfway house
was february 6th on my 30th birthday
and this was february so by july i was
this is when everything went down was in
july
okay so it's like five months okay so
then i go out to um
i go out to michigan and this time i was
like okay i'm [ __ ]
obviously i know i have a probate i just
absconded yeah i just absconded from
probation and i'm gonna have the
probation violation for
the the [ __ ] i just got popped right you
know so now i'm like you know i'm [ __ ]
pretty much so i'm in michigan i'm
[ __ ] partying it up staying at my
cousin's house just going on a rampage
just
drinking just knowing that it's all
coming oh yeah dude i'm going out with a
bang you know what i mean
and so i'm partying it up i'm like okay
i don't give a [ __ ] if whatever happens
happens
and uh my wife calls me up she's in
nebraska she says i'm pregnant
i need you to come out here i said all
right
you know what i mean at this time i'm
like [ __ ] i can get the [ __ ] i'll go
hide in nebraska who the [ __ ] gonna
find me in nebraska
you know what i mean there's nothing out
there but corn you know that's it
yeah corn and cattle right that's it and
i'm [ __ ] i go hide in nebraska
in my mind i'm like that's the perfect
[ __ ] place i go out there you know
what i mean settle down i got the wife
got the kids out there i can [ __ ]
hide and maybe in a few years i'll be
able to work all this [ __ ] [ __ ] out
with a lawyer or something or maybe not
so i i go off and i go out to nebraska
and that started [ __ ] show number two
because it was just one [ __ ]
conundrum after another after i went out
dude
my this whole thing with my wife and i
went out there and
guys were bringing flowers by the house
and [ __ ] leaving bags of sugar at the
[ __ ] door and all kinds just all
kinds of
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] dude like yeah it's
like dude this chick
had every dude in this little town we
lived in wanted to [ __ ] her
you know what i mean and they just every
dude in the entire little [ __ ] town
because they knew we lived in town yeah
we lived we you know what i mean we had
nice cars and we lived in the house and
you know the main drag and you know she
went to mcdonald's every morning for a
coffee and
we both worked at these these small um
um manufacturing plants right in this
little tiny small
town in nebraska and um
yeah i mean [ __ ] went sideways out there
real [ __ ] fast
she started you know doing meth and
[ __ ] around with
you know scumbags and here i am like i
don't do drugs you know what i mean like
i smoke pot
which is a drug so apparently i'm a drug
addict and a liar you're nothing like
any of these other guys yeah
[Music]
you know you're completely normal yeah
you know but like i'm not doing the
hardcore drugs
right not [ __ ] i've never done heroin
right i'm not smoking crack i'm not
[ __ ] i'm not doing that [ __ ] you know
i'm a [ __ ] i'm a stoner
i don't even really drink that much you
know i barely ever drink
so you know [ __ ] goes sideways out there
dude she so the baby's born
with meth in his system bomb they take
our kids away
they take our kids away [ __ ] i got a
warrant for my arrest
i'm laying in a hospital bed with her
here come two [ __ ] cops
into the [ __ ] hospital room
wanting to lock her up and me up for
drugs and this whole [ __ ] thing i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is going on and i didn't
even know she was doing meth like i had
no idea
she was doing meth while she was [ __ ]
pregnant because i had to go and work at
the [ __ ] i was working yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] all bad yeah [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
so that happened and then our kids got
taken away
um find out the little girl not mine
not even yours i knew right away when
the baby was born she wasn't mine that
it was the other dude that she had
living
at her [ __ ] mom and dad's house with
her after i got out of here you knew
right when the baby was born
right away how sorry yeah i knew right
away how'd you know right oh i looked at
her i looked at her earlier yeah
i looked for sure one thousand percent
because i knew what the kid looked like
all right and this little girl looks
just like that [ __ ] kid i mean
it's his 1 000 i mean even the dates
don't match up
because when she when she was when she
had the baby and i was like wait a
minute i was in the halfway house and we
had and i remember i was like we had sex
this day
this is doing the math you're like i'm
doing the math like this [ __ ] just
doesn't [ __ ] jive
dude this and you know what i mean but
here i'm trying to give her the benefit
of the doubt or
well you know we had we had already had
my son together and i knew he's mine for
sure
and you know i still love her and even
to this day i still love her i still
love her to death and we're still
married
even though i haven't talked to her in
months and we've been separated for four
years i haven't seen her in four years
and since nebraska so this whole thing
went down in nebraska and you know our
kids get taken away
excuse me and i have a warrant for my
arrest
because i just took off from after all
this [ __ ] just happened down here in
in florida let me get some water
it's just getting wild i'm parched yeah
now i'm i'm
because yeah keep in mind by this point
i'm i'm done with the with the book
right it's been written yeah we're into
book number two now yeah yeah yeah
yeah like i said this whole this whole
whole another situation
and um yeah so you know the cops
they get involved and i got a warrant
for my arrest so i'm like [ __ ] dude what
the [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'm in my head i'm
like dude this [ __ ] just [ __ ] me you
know what i mean like i came out here to
[ __ ] chill
and you [ __ ] me because you're an
idiot you know what i mean
so the [ __ ] police get involved and
you know sure enough they finally figure
out who i am and they run my name
and they came to the house to get me one
morning and this is the whole thing they
tell you this story so okay so these
these cops show up the gummies wore off
yeah it's all coming to him
pulling teeth before yeah yeah
and um so so i'm working i'm working at
this little machine shop uh next door to
the house and in this
in this small town in nebraska and i'm
over there at work and i see two
i see two sheriff's uh cars roll up to
my house
and i already knew what time it was so i
called my wife and i and i was right
next door i'm like
like the police are outside i'm going to
jail she's like what where i'm like
they're outside the house
she's like okay just stay over there and
i was like listen if they know where i
live they know where i work
you know what i mean he lives here he
works there it's not very [ __ ] hard
so i remember what happened i think they
left she told him i wasn't there and
they left
and then they drove around the back of
the shop and then so i leave the front
door of the shop and i walk into the
house
and i'm [ __ ] hiding inside the house
and like the cops are like surrounding
the house now they know i have a warrant
for my arrest they know who i am they're
there to [ __ ] take me to jail
they got the whole [ __ ] house
surrounded dude they're baiting on the
door they got flashlights in the windows
my wife's not my wife's out there
just arguing with him on the front lawn
like he's not here my wife
my wife bless her heart she's five foot
even
120 pounds and she's cuban and her
english isn't you know what i mean
not like ours you can tell she's not a
native you know so she's out there
arguing with them
they finally come in the house they
finally find me in the basement i'm
inside of a cabinet
i'm hiding inside of a [ __ ] cabinet
inside of the basement i can hear them
all walking around the house for like an
hour searching for me i'm not coming
i'm not coming out [ __ ] you
guys have to come down here and find me
hide and seek [ __ ] you know
what i mean you're it
you dig what i'm saying so i'm in the
basement i'm inside of a cabinet and i'm
small so i can curl up in a ball
and they pull open the cabinet door and
he shines the light in there
and i just stay still and he closes the
cabinet
and he was like and they were going to
walk away and then i heard i heard i
heard the footsteps stop and then i
heard somebody say something real low
all right he saw you yeah i heard him
say somebody real low and then they
[ __ ] yank open the cab and they got
the tasers on me they got two of them
with tasers on me
i'm like fog and they're like come out
your hands up
you know what i mean i'm trying to crawl
out of this [ __ ] cabinet dude and
just grab my arm they yank me out of the
[ __ ] cabinet
dude i come outside i'm getting arrested
my wife is fighting the police
she's physically fighting the police in
the front yard god bless her
yeah yeah that's what i said like all
right she's going ham for me yeah
i mean like she's [ __ ] going ham
she's screaming she's fighting the
police she gets arrested
they arrest us both right there take us
both to jail yeah our kids were already
taken away they were in like a [ __ ]
foster care or whatever like that we
both go to jail
uh yeah so this was november of 2015
is when i started this little journey is
when i when i got arrested
and we both went to jail and everything
i didn't get to south carolina excited
to go back and see my
judge in south carolina because that's
where my warrant was i had a federal
warrant out of the
southern district of southern carolina
northern district southern carolina